LEONARD LAW: Good
morning, everyone.
Hope you had a good
start to the show.
My name is Leonard Law.
I'm a product manager on the
Google Cloud Platform team
and in my capacity,
I've had the privilege
of working with many of our
largest enterprise customers.
But a little bit about me.
Before joining Google, I've
worn a number of different hats.
I was an entrepreneur.
I started a too early for
its time social media site.
I was a consultant who
spent many years working
with a number of e-commerce
firms, an engineer building
many different applications
and technologies.
And finally, for the decade
prior to joining Google,
I was a CIO on Wall Street.
And I tell you
this because I like
to think that I have something
in common with many of you
in the room.
You know, I was in your
shoes, and for a long time,
I was a prospective
buyer of Cloud.
Now I was interested in Cloud
as a CIO for quite a long time.
What I realized was
that I spent too much
of my time and my budget
on the things that
were necessary to
keep the lights on.
And inversely, I
spent too little time
on things that really
would give my company
a competitive advantage.
Cloud was this
thing that I thought
could unlock agility and
productivity and innovation,
but every time I tried to start
up a new Cloud initiative,
it felt like I got a roadblock
from somebody in Security
or Compliance or Risk.
I want to take a quick
moment to tell you
a story that really
made the Cloud value
proposition real for me.
So as I mentioned, I was the
CIO of an investment management
firm.
And as you might imagine, we
had to hold a lot of investor
records in our systems.
Those investment
records included things
like names, addresses, social
security numbers, tax IDs,
stuff that you would classically
defined as personally
identifiable information.
Of course, this is a nightmare.
But we worked with our auditors
to come up with a strategy
to secure this data.
And what we did was
we encrypted all
of that data using Windows
Server 2003's Encrypting File
System.
We set up our records
management system
to be the only account that
had access to that certificate.
Of course, you can imagine that
this story doesn't end well
and that certificate ended
up getting corrupted.
And the lessons that
I learned after that
were pretty frightening.
So fortunately, we had a
backup of the private key
and that backup was in one of
my employees' personal Gmail
boxes.
It turned out the operations
manager, really nice guy,
but he was really just
a glorified speed dial
to Microsoft Support.
And it was at that
point that I realized
that Cloud was not
really nice to have,
it was a requirement for me.
Because at the end
of the day, there
was no way that
my infrastructure
folks would become sort
of a core competency
for my business.
And so Cloud was
something that was
much more than just
something to drive agility
and to create efficiency.
It was, in fact, something
that I needed to reduce risk
for my organization.
And so you have this sort
of vision of Cloud and Cloud
can be this amazing thing.
Right?
It unlocks all
these opportunities.
I like to think about it
as Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory for an IT worker.
You can imagine this
world where infrastructure
can scale up from zero to
infinity and back on demand.
Right?
No more headaches
with procurement.
Imagine a world
where you don't have
to worry about patch Tuesday.
Software is upgraded
automatically,
zero days are patched
on your behalf.
Imagine a world where
your software developers
can focus on just writing
code, instead of trying
to run infrastructure.
And finally, imagine a
world where I can actually
make sense of all this data
that I've been collecting.
In short, Cloud for
me, was something
that could truly transform
information technology
into business technology.
But as you all know, it's
not such a simple story.
In fact, moving to
Cloud today can be hard.
And so I'm going to spend
the rest of this talk talking
about sort of three major
areas that companies
tend to think about when
initiating their move to Cloud.
The first is security
and compliance,
and when I speak here,
mostly about data protection.
The next is on keeping
operational control
over a vast set of
Cloud resources.
And the last is how do
you make sure Cloud can
work with my existing assets?
So over the last few
years, I'm sure you've seen
a headline like one of these.
And nothing catches the
attention of an executive
or a board member like
an explosive headline.
Back in 2011, Experian conducted
a survey called the Reputation
Impact of a Data Breach.
And what they found was
that the average brand
lost $184 to $332
million of brand value
when incurring a major breach.
So the first thing that
companies typically think about
is data protection, or
as I like to call it,
how to keep the boss
out of jail and how
to avoid making the
wrong headlines.
So at Google, the
first thing we think
about when it comes
to protecting data
is encryption at rest.
And we believe this is an
imperative capability that
is required across
the entire platform.
And so at Google, all data is
encrypted at rest by default,
automatically.
We also recognize,
though, that customers
desire amount of control over
how their data is encrypted.
And so we were fortunate to
work with a number of customers,
including those from highly
regulated industries,
to understand sort of the
trade offs between fully
automated management and
fine grained control.
And so what we've done
is we've introduced
a couple of new features.
The first is customer managed
keys using our Cloud KMS.
And that's a model that allows
you to store and maintain
keys in Google Cloud, but
also to still control things
like rotation, creation,
revocation, and so on.
And finally, we created customer
supplied encryption keys which
is a novel feature
in a cloud platform
which actually keeps encryption
keys only if I'm really
in the Cloud.
What this means
is that customers
can provide a key to
Google and encrypt
the data on their
behalf using that key,
but Google will never
persist that key on the cloud
so that any time that
that data is at rest,
Google has no access to
decrypting that data.
I'm very pleased to
announce, or sorry,
to introduce Patrick
Lecuyer, who was formerly
the head of IaaS and PaaS
Security at Morgan Stanley
and now the head
of cybersecurity
at Lightspeed HQ, who was
one of the customers who
helped us to come up with
some of these models.
So Patrick's going
to talk a little bit
about where he thinks these
use cases are appropriate.
PATRICK LECUYER:
Thank you, Leonard.
So, yes, so I used to
work at Morgan Stanley,
now at Lightspeed
HQ, so still in close
to the financial industry.
At Morgan Stanley,
when we started
looking at moving
workloads to the cloud,
one of the big
concerns that we had
was around encryption
of confidential data.
And the first
approach that we took
was to actually try to figure
out and choose the encryption
controls we would
put in place in terms
of data classification.
So standard data classification
is either public, confidential,
or restricted.
And we very quickly figured
out that those classic data
classification are
not all that relevant
when you're talking about
encryption controls.
Because the reality is
that most of your data
is confidential anyway.
You don't have that
much public data.
And in order to figure out
what's the best encryption
control to put in place, we
had to look more closely at how
we wanted to protect the data.
So we figured that within that
large category of data that's
confidential data,
we actually had
different concerns around
different classes of data
within that.
And this is where the model
that Google is offering
is actually extremely
interesting.
And when we're
looking at that data,
and if we move from the
fully automated mode
all the way to the
finer grain, the default
encryption that
Google offers actually
allowed us to have basic
encryption interests.
We call this the way that we
called it, and still call it,
in the e-commerce industry,
that's compliance encryption.
So your regulator asks you to
add something that's encrypted,
you can say it's encrypted.
And when you look at the white
papers that Google publish,
it's actually very
well encrypted.
You have a strong
key management.
The thing it doesn't give
you is a lot of flexibility
or a lot of understanding
of what's happening.
Encrypting is one
thing, but figuring out
how the data is used
and figuring out
how the keys are
released is actually
much more important than
encrypting itself, especially
as you want to protect against
most sophisticated threats.
So fine grained encryption,
OK for compliance,
it protects against
the basic threats.
It protects against
physical threats
on Google's
infrastructure, it protects
against disk based threats,
but as you move to data
where you want to protect
against threats that would come
from somewhere else, you want
to move and have more visibility
over that encryption.
And this is where the
second model with Cloud
came as a customer managed
encryption keys actually brings
you a lot more visibility.
Because right now,
at that point,
Google doesn't control
the keys anymore.
They hold the key for
you, they give you
a way to to segregate
duties to create auditing
and to really understand
how your data is used.
So that's interesting because
one of the major threat that we
figured out we wanted to
use encryption against
was not all that
much threats that
were coming from the
outside, but threats which
were coming from the inside.
We were more worried about our
own operation people making
the mistake and by
mistake, leaking data,
that we were about a
sophisticated intruder trying
to decrypt our data.
And that's a concern that's
really particular to Cloud
because we gain a lot
of agility in the cloud,
but as we gained
that agility, we also
end up losing some control
and we end up increasing risk
that a mistake will happen.
And we found that by
using encryption and using
some of the controls
around Cloud KMS,
about how keys are released
and how we can segregate duties
about people who can
encrypt and decrypt data,
there is a way to prevent some
of the accidental data leak
issues that might
come from the cloud.
So that's very interesting.
For most confidential data,
when you want to worry
and make sure that your data--
you will gain your
key visibility
and you will be able
to keep disaggregation
of duties that's extremely
hard to implement in Cloud.
It's a very good model.
And then we have the data that
leads to the type of headlines
that was in previous slides.
So there are datas,
and every industry
has that data, that's
not only confidential,
but has some regulatory
requirements around it.
It might be your client data.
It might be payment
card industry data.
It may be health data.
It's the kind of data
that if it ever gets out,
you will need to answer
some very hard questions
from your regulators.
And this is where moving,
again, one way up the stack
and moving from a place
where Google holds your key
and gives you very
good auditing over them
to a place where you actually
can manage your own key
and provide the keys and keep
full control over the lifecycle
of that keys, and providing
it when you make an action,
and be able to scope that
key release to one very
specific action that one
authorized user has taken,
allowed us to answer
those questions,
when or if they came,
way more precisely.
Because now we add
full visibility
over how the data was
being used because we were
the one releasing the keys.
So in a context where
you have regulators
and you want to be able to
answer very quickly, OK, there
was a data breach, could it have
come from the cloud provider?
Could it have come
from a mistake?
Could it have come from
an external attacker?
Being able to control precisely
how that key is released
is actually a very,
very strong control.
But again, there's cost
to managing your own keys
so finding that
right balance really
depends on those
requirements and how
you want to keep the visibility
to that control of your keys.
So by looking at it
from a threat management
point of view, rather than
from a data classification
point of view, I think
it allows to have
a much clearer vision on
how the keys should be used,
should be managed.
And this really allows
to align very efficiently
with that model that
Google presents.
So, yeah.
Thank you.
LEONARD LAW: Great.
Thank you, Patrick.
So as Patrick
described, you know
encryption is a multi-faceted
decision that needs to be made.
I encourage you all to
check out Session IO214,
Managing Encryption
of Data on the Cloud.
It's happening on Friday.
OK.
So let's say we've sorted
out our encryption strategy.
It still may be the case that
we want to do a little bit more.
Oftentimes, we may be
managing sensitive data.
Maybe we don't know what
data is moving to the cloud
and we need to figure out
how sensitive that data is.
Maybe we are hosting
sensitive data in the cloud
and we want to be careful that
that data doesn't leak out.
One example might be you
have an e-commerce site
and maybe, you've built
the customer service app,
you want to make sure that that
customer service app doesn't
accidentally allow a customer
service agent to leak PI
information over online chat.
For this, we have a number
of partners that can help us.
And some very
exciting announcements
that Diane mentioned will
be announced tomorrow,
so I encourage you,
again, to come out
to session IO218 which will be
happening tomorrow afternoon.
And I would be remiss to talk
about in any kind of migration
story without giving
a nod to our partners.
So in the space of
data protection,
we have a number a selection
of partners that we work with.
For example, IONIC Security,
which is a Google Ventures
backed company,
provides high assurance
and high throughput encryption
key and entitlements management
solutions for
global organizations
like Goldman Sachs, Aetna, ADP,
and the Department of Defense.
One of their products, IONIC
Protect for Cloud Storage,
enables developers to simply
and seamlessly use their own one
time use encryption keys
with the full capabilities
of the IONIC platform,
but integrate it natively
with Google Cloud Storage.
Another partner, KeyNexus,
provides centralized platform
agnostic key management
solution that
can be deployed on a
variety of architectures,
both in the cloud
and on premise,
and it helps to enable
a variety of bring
your own key scenarios.
KeyNexus integrates
directly with GCP,
including our G Cloud client
interface for Google Compute
Engine, as well as the
gsutil SDK for Cloud Storage.
In both cases, this allows
customers to leverage
the customer supplied
encryption key functionality
that I talked about,
but using keys
that are stored in
KeyNexus and allowing
for the rotation and
federated management
that pattern provides.
From here, I'd like to
introduce Sol Cates.
Sol is the Vice President of
Technical Strategy at Thales
and he's going to spend a few
minutes talking about what
their company brings to bear.
SOL CATES: Thank you.
Hello?
Hello, computer.
There we go.
Excellent.
So as Leonard said,
I'm Sol Cates.
I'm the VP of Technical
Strategy for Thales.
Prior to the acquisition,
I was with a company
called Vormetric which some
of you might be familiar with.
And I want to talk
about two sort of things
that are interesting to us in
conjunction with Google Cloud.
So as most of you
know, going to Cloud
is a shared responsibility.
I was a CSO for many years
so I also agree with Leonard.
One of the challenges as
you go to new technologies,
like Cloud in particular,
it's figuring out
where the line in the
sand from innovation
versus control perspective.
How do we make sure that we're
leveraging the technology
effectively, getting
the value we need out
of it as quickly as possible,
and making sure we're not
running into a burning fire?
So if you guys haven't seen
the Cloud Security Alliance,
I highly recommend you
research them a little bit.
They have a lot of great models
about how to do Cloud securely,
particularly when
it comes to things
like shared responsibilities.
What is your responsibility as
the buyer of this technology?
What are you supposed to operate
from a control perspective?
All the way from SaaS platforms
down to infrastructure
as a service, so it's a
very good resource if you
haven't looked at it yet.
And the reason I
bring it up is I
see most Cloud
buyers traditionally
either came from the IT
side and not security.
So when they're looking for how
do I actually successfully move
to Cloud securely,
having resources
like the Cloud Security
Alliance is a very, very good
first step.
And they got tons of great
tools for you to use.
So I did actually want
to talk a little about
a couple announcements
that we have with Google.
We have just launched
our Vormetric Transparent
Encryption technology into
the Test Drive capability.
So up on Orbitera, so you can
go check it out and actually
play with a transparent
encryption technology
that we've been using
for about 15 years
to solve a fundamental
problem I'll
talk about here in a minute.
And then we also supported
the bring your own key
for the ephemeral
keys that are going
into the customer supplied keys.
So you can actually
back the key material
that you're using to encrypt
data inside your instances
and drives up within Google
with HSM backed cryptography.
The keys never actually leave
that HSM without being wrapped
and then they're imported
into the cloud provider,
in this case Google,
in ephemeral ways
so the data and the
keys are separated.
So Thales as a
company is fairly big.
We do a lot of big things.
We throw stuff into space.
We build aircraft carriers.
But we also
specialize in security
and we have a fairly
large portfolio.
I'm going to focus
on a couple of things
today that might be of
interest, particularly
on that gradient scale of
security we were just talking
about a couple minutes ago,
everything from compliance
encryption all the way up to
that very, very tactical, very
sensitive information I had
to be very concerned with.
And one of the technologies
I wanted to focus on
is Vormetric
Transparent Encryption.
It's something that's
been around for about 15,
16 years now.
And just because it's old,
doesn't mean it's bad.
We sort of got the architecture
the right way the first time.
We had designed a
technology to help combat
a very serious
threat that we saw
within the infrastructure
of most IT departments
and that is root, the God
of the operating system,
the DBA of the database.
Right?
Those privileged users had
unfettered access to the data
and we'll talk a little
bit about why that is.
So the transparent
encryption technology
has been around
for quite a while.
It focuses on just about
any kind of data type,
any kind of infrastructure.
It can run in Cloud.
It can run in hybrid mode,
the unphysical systems,
legacy platforms,
next generation,
container backed applications.
It's fairly flexible.
We designed to be
so many years ago.
And as new
innovations happen, we
make sure that we
embrace and support them.
And really the notion
is data should always
be in a protected state.
I really like the
fact that Google
is taking a stance as well
as, at the minimum, encrypted
at rest.
Right?
Even if it's a transparent key
that's governed to your tenant,
that's better than zero.
Right?
So it's slightly
better than zero.
Then you have that
gradient scale
to get all the way up to that
very sensitive information,
because I've been
doing this for 15
years in different capacities
in the encryption space,
no one does encryption
because they want to.
It's something
compels them to do so.
It's either a risk reduction,
it's a compliance requirement,
it's a customer screaming at
them, some reason to change.
And encryption is actually
not the hardest part to do.
That's the easiest thing to do.
It's all the
complexity around it--
key management,
separation of duties,
who can see this data,
under what conditions,
so on and so forth.
So we built a technology to
combat the privileged user,
in particular, in
the Unix environment
at the very beginning,
but then we actually
enhanced it over
the last 15 years
to be very transparent
and extendable.
So what we do is we encrypt data
at rest inside your operating
systems and VMs.
And again, this is
just one product
out of the multitude
of the portfolio
because we can go all the
way up to tokenization.
But a lot of our organizations
like to focus on need to know.
If you guys ever worked in
the intelligence community
or worked in DoD
or any place where
you have these
compartmentalisation
of different types of
data, you understand
the concept of having the need
to know or the right to know.
And what we did was
build a technology
that actually encrypts data
at rest and then to leave
that state of encryption.
You have to be the right
user doing the right thing
the right way with the
right authentication.
It's a policy based
approach to saying
who is the right
user of this data
and when should they see it?
So we just launched this in
Test Drive this last week.
So you can now actually go
out and play with it, but what
this does it actually allows
you, through policy, to say
which users on this platform
should ever see this data.
And a user, nine times out
of 10, is an application.
All right?
It's a container.
Which data should I be using?
Which service account should
access this information?
And the reason it's
important is if you
look at every single data
breach you probably read about
in the last five,
six years, there's
a common thing that happens
at the very end of the data
breach--
escalate privilege, steal data.
Well, we took the privilege
away many years ago.
If you employ
something like this,
it allows you to get much
more granular as to what
and who and why information
can be accessed in a clear way.
Right?
The default stance
is keep it protected.
To leave this stance,
you've got to authenticate
the appropriate way.
And then with that, again,
another part of the portfolio
is we do a lot of
key management.
So we've just put
some investments
in over the last six months
or so to actually support
bringing your own key into
multiple cloud providers.
We see a common problem here.
This is sort of the
way that my team works.
We start with the problem, we
work towards the technology.
There is a common problem,
it's just cloud key management.
As cloud providers,
such as Google,
are turning on more and
more encryption capabilities
within their frameworks,
the need for the enterprise
to actually manage those keys
is growing, it's increasing.
But the challenge is
every single provider
is doing it slightly different.
They have different concepts,
different architectures,
different APIs you work with.
So we actually invested
in creative technology
what we called our key
management as a service that
actually allows you to back
all these key managers as they
evolve over the
next couple of years
from one single pane of glass
with keys managed and stored
on prem.
So you have that flexibility
of [INAUDIBLE] in a cloud using
those infrastructure,
that service, those paths,
applications that you would
like to, and ground it
in key material, and
governance is done
on prem in traditional
HSMs and then,
of course, our Data Security
Manager which is part
of the Vormetric portfolio.
And with that, thank you.
And if you want to come chat,
we have a booth here, C3.
Thank you.
LEONARD LAW: Great.
Thanks, Sol.
[APPLAUSE]
So let's assume that we've
made some decisions around data
protection.
The next thing that really
scares a lot of people
is how do we manage
these resources at scale.
Right?
One of the nightmares
that I used to have
is the 100 tab spreadsheet
that my auditors gave me
for SOX compliance.
And imagine applying
that spreadsheet
to the sort of
limitless resources
that are afforded
to you in Cloud.
It's not a good place to be.
And so clearly, being able
to manage resources at scale
is imperative to controlling the
risk as you move into the cloud
environment.
And so I want to talk
about a couple of things.
The first step that
you want to take
when trying to control
resources in Google Cloud
is to start with the
access management patterns
that you're going to
apply for your resources.
And so what you can
do is in Cloud IAM,
you can set up fine grained
roles and permissions
that define the patterns
that can access your cloud
resources.
Next, by grouping those
resources into our resource
hierarchy, you can create
some organizational constructs
and that logical
grouping allows you
to then apply those actions and
policies in an inherited way.
And finally, at
the top level, we
have these organization
wide policies
that can help you
to create limits
that enforce certain constructs
within your Cloud platform
deployment.
For example, you might want
to create a policy that
says under no circumstances
should a user be
able to have serial port access
to a Compute Engine instance.
And that's something you would
set at a high level policy
level.
We believe very much in sort
of a belt and suspenders
model for security,
and so in addition
to being able to
set the policy, we
want to be able to verify the
activity that's happening.
So GCP provides a very robust
audit logging capabilities
which keeps track of both your
administrative and potentially
data access events that are
happening on Google Cloud.
Again, there's going to be a
much deeper dive on this topic,
please check out
session IO211 for how
to control your organization's
Cloud resources.
It's going to be a good session.
I want to go back to
partners again here.
In this particular
space, I think partners
are especially important.
As customers are looking at
hybrid cloud and multi cloud
worlds, it's very
likely that they
have resources not just
in GCP, but also spread
across multiple infrastructures.
So take, for example, Qualys.
Qualys provides their
virtual scanner appliance
for GCP which extends the
same multilayered security
that customers are used to
running in their own data
centers to Google cloud.
Users can now scan
GCP resources using
both multi Cloud and
on premise assets
from within the Qualys Cloud.
The virtual scanner appliance is
certified by Google and cannot
be directly deployed from
the Google Cloud Launcher.
Users can also embed the
Qualys Cloud agents directly
into their GCE images for a
continuous view on security
and compliance events.
Another partner that I'm
excited to talk about is Brinqa.
Brinqa has a cloud sale
cybersecurity risk management
tool for GCP.
With Brinqa, customers get
a comprehensive visibility
into their cloud and
data center resources
along with the ability to
measure and manage risk
across several key security
concerns, like asset
inventory, vulnerability
management, policy compliance,
and privileged
access monitoring.
The Brinqa risk
platform analyzes
data from both native
GCP APIs, as well as
best of breed assessment
services across the Google
Cloud Platform ecosystem
which can give you complete
visibility, insight, and
command over cybersecurity
and it's going to be available
in Cloud Launcher very soon.
And then finally, MetricStream
has an IT GRC solution
which provides customers
with a great end
to end solution that
enables them to scope,
plan, and achieve cloud
asset security, transparency,
governance, and compliance.
So as customers
expand in the cloud,
particularly with multi cloud
and hybrid cloud deployments,
partners like these are
invaluable to helping
to maintain operational
governance over your technology
portfolio.
I'd like now to introduce
Roy Feintuch to the stage.
Roy is the CTO of
Dome9, which is
another very interesting company
whose working with Google
Cloud.
ROY FEINTUCH:
Thank you, Leonard.
And thank you for not
messing up my name.
Do you-- wait a second.
So we started our journey to
the cloud or cloud security
more than six years ago
where my partner Zoran
myself tried to
re-imagine what does
it mean to create an
infrastructure security
service, but purpose
built into the cloud.
Six years later,
fast forward to now,
Dome9 Security is
protecting some
of the largest and most
complex cloud environments
within Amazon and Azure.
And our announcement
is, as of today, we've
got announcing the availability
of the Dome9 ARC platform
to GCP customers, as well.
So what does it bring to you?
And I would like to
start with some question.
How many of you are familiar
with this unicorn piglet?
Well, not too many, but
this toy it's called
Cloud Pets is a
cloud enabled toy
which allows kids to talk
with their family members.
It was announced last week
that the company, Spiral Toys,
had leaked over 2 million
of audio recordings of kids
talking with their
family, together
with some personal information.
And that's kind of
just one incident out
of tens of thousands of
incidents during last quarter
where the kind of
common denominator
was some data store,
mostly open source,
but this doesn't really mean--
MongoDB Server,
Elasticsearch Server
being deployed to
the public cloud
said they're not properly
configured, totally accessible
from the entire internet.
And then with some lack
of authentication or not
too strong authentication, it
was hijacked by the attacker
and then ransomwared,
et cetera, et cetera.
And that kind of leads
me to the first issue
with maintaining
workloads in the cloud,
the operational visibility.
What's my network exposure?
What's my DMZ?
And where are my
IT assets at all?
And even if we identify a
specific critical element
like this MongoDB server,
what's the effective security
posture, network security
posture, of that element?
With that, I would
like to show you
the Dome9 system and
how we help protecting
against these kinds of issues.
Let's switch to the demo.
OK.
So what you're seeing now
is one of the capabilities
of the platform which
it's called Clarity which
now connects natively
to the GCP APIs,
process all the workloads,
configuration policies,
and then builds these kind
of visual map of your assets
and their exposure.
So right now,
trying to understand
what is my DMZ is a
symbol just looking
at the swim lane of the DMZ or
clicking on this internet node
and seeing all the
members, all my assets
there are exposed directly
to the entire internet.
So kind of understanding
that they have this Mongo
member here with public IP
address and this port TCP
27017, the MongoDB port,
talking with the entire internet
is now a trivial thing.
Now that system also allows
you to understand and analyze
the firewall rules, the GCP
firewall rules, and the subnets
in order to really understand
how different assets
communicate between themselves.
So really allowing you
to tighten these micro
segmentation-- it's
a nice buzzword--
so tighten this
up and really make
sure you've got your
security interconnectivity
between your intercomponents
kind of [INAUDIBLE].
Let's move back to
the presentation.
OK.
The next topic I
would like to attach
is compliance and governance.
Although this is an old
topic, but transferring that
into the cloud brings
new challenges.
So how do I adhere to my
existing complex regulations--
BCI, HIPAA, you name it?
And on top of that,
also, how do I
adhere to my internal
corporate ID policies?
And how do I translate those
policies to my GCP environment?
So I would like to introduce
you to the Dome9 Compliance
Engine which is an automated
compliance and governance
system that allows you
to test your GCP project,
your GCP environments against
industry best practices,
against complex
regulations, and in turn,
your own custom
internal IT policies.
Let's see that in action.
Switch to the demo, please.
OK.
So here we are seeing the
compliance and governance
viewing the Dome9 ARC
platform and we're
going to pick from a
number of policies,
we call them bundles--
just container for rules.
And I'll take the best
practices for the GCP bundle
and I would like to
run an assessment
against one of my GCP projects.
So now Dome9, in the
background, performing
hundreds of tests against
my assets and my policies.
And almost in less than 10
seconds, gave me that report.
Let me drill down
into the failed tests
and into the high severity ones.
And I can see that I
have these Mongo member
backup in the Western Union
kind of automatically detected
by the system.
As I promise, it's not only
testing against Dome9 best
practices or industry
best practices,
it can also allow you
to model your own best
practices, your own
internal IT policies
and model them in the cloud.
So as just an example, I created
a little policy with only two
tests that allows my instances--
let me try to increase that--
allows my instances to only
operate on specific user
regions or that no firewall
rules should allow us
to say to the entire internet.
Now these rules,
those policies, are
created in what we call GSL,
the Governance Specification
Language, which allows
you to create something
like English SQL
kind of statements
and that allow you to create
your own specific custom
governance, too.
Back to the presentation.
So if you'd like to hear more
about the product, we are here,
we have a nice team
here at booth A20.
Feel free to give us a visit.
We are kind of
friendly people there.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LEONARD LAW: Thanks, Roy.
OK.
So to recap, we've talked
about data protection,
we've talked about applying
some operational control
to your environment.
The next thing
companies typically
think about is, well,
how is this all going
to work with my
existing infrastructure?
Companies have made existing
investments in infrastructure
and data centers.
You have relationships
with key partners and ISVs.
And you want to make sure
that everything plays nicely
together and you want
to make sure, also,
that you're not getting locked
into any decision you make.
So the first step is typically
to extend your network
into Google Cloud Platform.
And we have a number of
ways that you can do this.
We have Carrier Interconnect
which provides enterprise grade
connections to Google using
Interconnect Carrier Service
provider partners.
You can also do
Direct Peering which
allows you to connect
directly to Google
for high levels of traffic.
And then we're,
very soon this year,
going to be rolling out Private
Interconnect and Partner
Interconnect which allows
easy RFC 1918 private
addressing to be used on GCP.
Of course, all of your data and
all your internet connections
can be secured via VPN and you
can segment off your network
from the outside world in
our Virtual Private Cloud.
I could spend all day
talking about network,
but there are actually
three sessions that I would
direct you to, in this case.
IO210 is actually
happening right now.
So if it's of interest you,
please check out the replay.
Otherwise, IO344 is a blueprint
on security for your workloads.
That's happening tomorrow at 11.
And IO401 is a view
on our VPC strategy
and that's happening
today at 4:00.
Again, when you talk
about hybrid cloud,
there are a number
of partners that
are very important
in this space,
for example, CrowdStrike.
CrowdStrike, as organizations
move their sensitive data
and computing capabilities
to Google Cloud Platform,
they need to protect
the endpoints
in a hybrid environment.
So CrowdStrike has
a Falcon Platform,
which is a next generation
endpoint protection
and it enables customers
to seamlessly migrate
their on-prem
security to the cloud.
Falcon is a Cloud
native ecosystem
and provides continuous
threat protection
from malware, non malware
threats on endpoints
and servers, regardless of where
they are physically located,
be they on the network
or hosted in GCP.
Likewise, Trend Micro has a deep
security hybrid cloud solution,
which enables organizations
to securely move
to the Google Cloud Platform
without compromising security.
It helps organizations meet
their shared responsibility
in the cloud by offering
dev apps friendly workload
protection, a uniform security
visibility and management
of on-prem virtualized
public cloud,
and multiple security controls
to speed compliance virtually
patched against
vulnerabilities and proactively
defend against network
and application threats.
And I want to sort of wrap up
the talk on Google's philosophy
on open source and open APIs.
This is absolutely
critical to our story.
You know, recent
research suggests
that 82% of enterprises
have a hybrid cloud strategy
and that includes 1.5 public
and 1.7 private clouds.
And Google Cloud's
vision is to really help
customers to succeed in
an open multi-cloud world.
Over our history, we've released
over 20 million lines of code,
projects like Chromium,
TensorFlow, Kubernetes,
and so on, and we've incubated
a number of other projects
which have led to innovations
like Hadoop, HSpace, and so on.
So it's this devotion to open
source and open APIs that
means that customers can
continue to drive innovation,
without feeling locked
into Cloud Platform.
You can bring your
applications to Cloud,
but you can also run
those same applications
on premise or on another cloud.
And we believe that
being open is the best
way to achieve these hybrid
multi-cloud strategies
and we're committed
to helping customers
leverage these architectures
in a flexible and low risk way.
So with that, I just wanted
to tell everyone, again,
that we're committed to
helping to get your journey
to be secure to
Google Cloud Platform.